et n'ont justement pas sa position ne
lui confère pas possible d'aller
désordre il est là pour regret des
points particuliers qui relèvent
généralement d'une situation d'une
ambiance d'un contexte sécuritaire sont
en charge ensuite aux j'espère est au
courant militaire de la tv je vous
précise que monsieur benalla ou n'était
pas le seul dans cette zone d'interface
à nous transmettre
évidemment des renseignements et ensuite
c'est à l'autorité fonctionnelle
j'espère d'un côté comptent en milliards
de notre apprendre à bien sûr à prendre
les dispositions qui s'imposent
c'est une simple raison de cohérence
hiérarchique prend des décisions et
donne des ordres
celui qui en a régi timité d'une part et
d'autre part celui qu'elle a les moyens
alexandre benalla n'avait ne commandait
pas de service n'avait pas d'hommes sous
ses ordres
il n'avait donc pas les moyens ni
hiérarchique ni fonctionnel d'exercer
une quelconque forme d'autorité merci
mon général madame jourdain
il a été indiqué notamment par les
syndicats de police qu'il pouvait y
avoir des relations de frottement
j'utilise un euphémisme par rapport aux
termes qu'ils ont indiqué vous
connaissez entre monsieur b dallas et
les services il ne donne pas d'ordre
il donne des éléments d'ambiance de
quelle façon ces frottements peuvent se
produire au regard de ce que vous nous
décrivez comme étant les relations
existantes entre les forces de l'ordre
enfin celles qui assurent la sécurité et
monsieur benalla
l'homme à damas sénatrice vous fait plus
appel à mon imagination
kagame connaissance parce que en fait
personnellement moi je n'ai pas assisté
à des frottements friction conflit entre
à l'essence benalla et des services de
sécurité comment est ce que cela aurait
pu se traduire peut-être des divergences
d'opinion sur le terrain il est vrai que
là où se situerait éventuellement ces
zones de friction le commandant
militaire nier nier pas visuellement
donc moi je n'ai personnellement et on
n'a jamais relaté d'incidents de cette
nature avec les avec les services